this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you yes I'm going to talk to you
today a little bit about development of
a frost Hardy Mays variety and a lot
about assembling a trip scum genome so
that we can frost tolerance in trips to
come remote here okay so just to
motivate the project plants with longer
growing seasons accumulate more biomass
we're looking at light capture
efficiency and Miscanthus and names in
side-by-side replicated field trials and
we see that Miscanthus due to emerging
earlier and finessing later in the
season is able to maximize folio canopy
cover throughout the growing season and
essentially do more photosynthesis
resulting in 59% greater productivity so
can we emulate this in maize alright so
this is just a zoom in of the corn belts
we're looking at NDVI in averaged over a
two week window at the end of four
months so as I cycle through here we can
see the greenness and lasers yeah
greenness in this kind of area right
here right in the Corn Belt doesn't
really kick in until the end of July
which is after the summer solstice so
basically half of our growing season is
gone the for maize really gets kicking
now if we could develop a cold tolerant
maize variety it could potentially
overwinter in the southeastern US down
here it could be sown earlier in the
corn belts and it's been growing season
potentially getting its its canopy out
earlier and making better use of the
growing season and also potentially be
grown further north potentially as a
spring crop Oh in order to study
freezing tolerance and potentially
identify traits to move over to maize
we're looking at this species called
trips to come I'm realizing just now
that I don't have a nice picture of
trips come here I have some pictures of
sad trips to come a little bit later so
just bear with me it's a big bushy grass
but at the seedling stage it looks a lot
like maize so trips to come over winters
and temperate climates there's two main
species that are endemic to North
America trips come dr. Luiz and trips
come Florida on them it's their
distributions down on the bottom right
hand side of the pot here
trying to stand right in front of that
yeah so it this is a great degree of
natural variation for freezing tolerance
which exceeds that of nays it's very
closely related to maize having diverged
around 1.2 million years ago and it
shares the whole genome duplication
event things there even cross-compatible
although it's very tricky to get a
viable cross out of the two and it
hasn't undergone and domestication
bottleneck although I'll point out the
trips come floor Dhanam is isolated so
basically the southern tip of Florida
the whole states highlighted here but
really it's just found in a few counties
down in the southern tip that population
actually did undergo not a domestication
bottleneck but we expect that the
hypothesis is the last ice age
essentially it was it was trapped in a
refugium southern florida there and so
we expected have a much smaller
effective population size than trips
compact deloitte ease which is found
from North America all the way through
Central America and down into the South
America Peru there aren't natural
populations so just to talk a little bit
about the mapping population here this
is largely the work of Christy gulfs and
Nick lepak Christy Gaal was a former
postdoc and Butler lab essentially we
had a number of trips come dr. Loy days
and trips come floor dhanam collections
that were made by denise Kostich who was
our former lab manager and a series of
crosses were made between northern
varieties trips combat Deloitte ease and
then trips from Florida gnam these were
made reciprocally but essentially we
just picked the the f ones that were
viable and we selected one plant per
family from each viable cross we ended
up with 53 F ones that were then
clonally propagated as trips comes a
perennial you can just cut it in half
and plant the two halves and you have
you have a clone and then the f2 s have
been allowed I'm sorry the F ones have
been allowed to open pollinate in the
field through the last several years and
we collect the seed off of those F ones
and use that for our freezing screen
and we're taking a bulk segment analysis
approach here where we subjects the f2
seed which has been germinated under
greenhouse conditions to first cold
acclamation followed by like a
essentially a hard frost at minus 8
degrees C overnight temperature slowly
ramps down and they get three hours of
hard freeze let them recover a little
bit and then we phenotype them basically
for their maintenance of green leaf area
so you can see some sad plants in the
left and the susceptible bulk and happy
plants on the right and the tolerant
bulk so we take essentially the tails of
the phenotypic distribution we pull
tissue and then we sequence them now the
question arises what do we map them to
it is possible to map these reeds to
maize but as I said before the the
genomes while they have a lot in common
there was fundamentally different
architecture trip succumb has 18
chromosomes and a 3.5 you get based
genome while maize has a 2.3 gigabase
genome and only 10 chromosomes so that
motivates me to try to assemble a trip
scan genome and the technology we picked
was nanopore reads as I mentioned the
trips command maize genomes are highly
repetitive about 85 or greater percent
on repeat content so that makes short
read assembly on the challenge or at
least an expensive proposition nanopore
reads can reach clients of up to 200
base 200 thousand base pairs and so it
can potentially span intergenic regions
so we're looking at on the bottom right
here where it says Maine's intergenic
regions that's a distribution of the
distance between consecutive sets of
maize genes and the b73 genome and then
the top we're looking at the
distribution of minyan reads a nicely
cover the intergenic region so this is a
technology that can potentially span
those gaps and allow us to assemble a
structurally complete trip scum genome
the drawback for nanopore reads is their
high error rate of around 15% which is
far worse than Illumina but fortunately
there are new algorithms that are
designed to account for this and so
about 30 X of
of long reads greater than 10 KB is what
is typically recommended for assembly
I'll show you the results we've gotten
using that approach so just a quick
overview of our assembly pipeline here
so we start with our long reads we feed
those into a software program called
wtvp g2 which is incredibly fast we
tried a number of other assembly
algorithms including canoe which is
probably more well known many sm fly and
the me cats and essentially what the
size of this data set we're talking
about 100 Giga bases of reads or a 200
gigabyte Q bytes worth of files the
memory requirements for overlapping all
of the reads against each other were
prohibitive so none of the other
approaches worked WT dbg to not only
worked but it worked quickly so out from
WT BBG we get raw contig so just sort of
draft still high error rate context and
what we do is we take the long reads we
map them back to those contexts and we
use a program called rake on to
essentially call consensus in companies
that improves the accuracy can we do
this iteratively one to three times
while the accuracy continues to improve
I'll talk in a moment about how we
benchmark that accuracy and the final
step is to throw some short reads on top
again those short Illumina low error
rate reads and use those to you know to
correct the the residual base pair error
any base parent accuracies that remain
in the rake on corrected assembly and
out from that we get corrected context
these typically are much more fragmented
than a chromosome scale assembly but
they do contain a lot of structural
information okay so yeah the performance
of that pipeline depends a lot on genome
characteristics and the input data here
is a collaboration that we did with elad
oren he's an outdoors group from review
and this is a much smaller less complex
genome than trips a comb or maze at 450
mega bases with far lower repeat
contents and 30x worth of long read
coverage on this is 13 and a half
Kika basis which works out to roughly 1
min allen flow cell so that's a very
small amount of data for the Nana for by
contrast we need about 10 well 7 to 10
depending on yields of these flow cells
to get the same coverage for a genome
size of maze right so the resource usage
in terms of compute time is minimal on a
medium memory cbsyou high-performance
computer computing server
it took about 500 CPU hours but just in
terms of wall clock time this ran in
about a day and the assembly size was
about 85% of what was expected and the
when aligning this assembly to the QQ
most mellow reference we can see that
it's generally collinear
there's a little bit of off diagonal but
it aligns very well tiles most of the
assembly and then down here on the right
we're looking at a boo scope plot and
what this is busca stands for
benchmarking the universal single copy
orthologs but it's it's just telling you
how many of the single copy genes that
are conserved within the embryo phyto
seed plants are present and correctly
assembled within your assembly so we can
see that for the reference genome versus
the Polish assembly they have very
similar numbers we're just looking at
the size of the blue bar versus the red
bar so it looks very good there now
maize p39 and trips can floor Donham
these are two assemblies that I've been
working on maize p39 more as a test case
because it's inbred and we have a closer
reference in p73 the compute time is
substantially longer but the clock time
is again only one to two days so we're
really talking about very rapid genome
assembly here and the contiguity we get
out of these is not quite as good as we
get with the smaller less repetitive
genome we are getting four hundred
kilobases worth of context or four
hundred kilobases and 50 so that's
saying half of our assemblies and
context that size or larger ok so again
another boost go plot we're looking at
these two assemblies maize p39 and trip
scum florid on them
and we're just looking at the
improvement of the busca score as we
iteratively polish with Ray Khan and we
can see that the assembly doesn't much
improve with repeated rounds of break on
but once we throw the short reads on
there with a pylon we get close to to
the reference completeness and the same
is true for trips come flora Dunham now
here is some work that bashing song my
colleague postdoc in the buffer lab did
he designed an alternative to boosts go
called Tabasco or basically take a wider
set of genes from the Andrew begonias so
more specific to maze and trip succumb
and we align them at the nucleotide
level rather than at the protein level
and so it's a little bit less sensitive
to base power errors and we can see that
essentially of the the gene space that
is not being picked up by basco oh sorry
by Musco as completes is actually there
so even before we polish anything we do
have the building blocks of a complete
assembly so this is the way that we can
rapidly check where our assemblies are
at it helps us with tuning parameters
and iterating ok so then just a couple
of whole genome alignments so once we
have these assemblies we want to know
how good we did so we take our
assemblies and we align them against
some kind of reference as I showed
before with QQ missed Mello versus the
reference genome there so these are
again the maze of p39 assembly and the
trips come floor Dhanam assembly aligned
against the maze b73 that's our sort of
quality reference genome and we can see
that the the features are very similar I
think I don't have time to get into
what's going on in these little red
circles here essentially there's a lot
of duplication in the maize genome
inherently as I said before and we're
picking it up in both the trips to comb
and the maize assemblies so that's the
thing I might have to dig into a little
bit further
another characteristic to note is that
this is slightly darker red and this is
a more orange here so we have higher
percent identity in the maze assembly
against maize then the trips come in
assembly against maize so in summary our
assemblies show good of contiguity and
collinearity
with the reference genome so we can
produce them quickly
and that shows that de novo nanopore
assembly is tractable for a large
repetitive genomes however whole genome
alignment remains problematic and we're
still looking at strategies to benchmark
our assemblies and assess their
completeness and accuracy yeah
we're also looking for higher depth
Illumina for our assemblies that will
help us to polish more accurately for
trips come we only have about three X
which is less than needed to polish and
then at some point I need to get around
to actually mapping freezing tolerance
and an interesting evolutionary question
would be how genome fractionation has
proceeded in trips come versus maze so
yeah just in summation I'd like to thank
everyone buckler lab I think I got all
the names up there with a big lab right
now Christi Gault so was the one who
originated this project she's now at NRI
yeah but to thank my committee who
didn't make it up here yeah Turin
bashing strong Center and thank you all
take your questions the question was if
the if it's difficult to cross maze and
trip scream how do we propose moving any
traits that we identify intimate so the
answer would be genome editing if we can
identify specific alleles then we can
the plan is to is to attempts to edit
them both in a freezing acceptable
background and induce freezing tolerance
and then eventually into maze yep you
might have mentioned this and I missed
it but why did you decide to simple was
it just because it probably has has that
the bottleneck so the question was why
did we pick trips conferred on him to
assemble or not tap devotees and the
answer is we actually picked both the
reason this
killer species and one particular line
from the species came up is that it's
the majority it's a parent and I think
25 to 30 percent of the F one's about in
the field so it's it's alleles are over
represented in the population we do have
further plans to sequence dr. Lloyd use
and others this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu